Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt und,
heute gibt's wieder eine neue Ausgabe von Corona, extra, Corona, Wiki, wie auch immer. Wir es jetzt auch nennen wollen, auf jeden Fall unser regelmäßiges Update.
Ich bin Tim Brittlav und auf der anderen Seite des Kanals ist Pabel Meier, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, der Zwei-Wochen-Rhythmus passt gerade ganz gut, habe ich so den Eindruck, da kann man erstmal.
Ähm ganz gut bei bleiben. Ähm trotzdem die Dinge fangen langsam an, sich wieder zu bewegen. Da könnt's dann auch schnell wieder Weekly werden. So wie sich das derzeit abzeichnet.
Ja, wir haben auch ziemlich viel auf der Liste heute. Das könnte also eine etwas längere Sendung werden.
Das ist richtig, denn es gibt auch äh Neuigkeiten aus Digitalien, die äh anstehende Ausweitung der Co-Navarnet nach Europa. Das sollte jetzt so in den nächsten Tagen stattfinden. Da haben wir jetzt noch nichts gesehen, aber es gibt noch ein paar andere schöne Entwicklungen dazu,
zweiten Teil mehr, aber bevor wir hier äh mit den Zahlen in Deutschland anfangen, gucken wir nochmal kurz,
aufs Feedback zur letzten Sendung, was wir sonst immer so sträflich vermisst haben
Ähm erster Hinweis in den Kommentaren war, dass das von uns erwähnte Micro Co wird. Wir erinnern uns, dass es so ein ähm,
so ein Berechnungsmodell um Risiken einzuschätzen äh,
Wenn ich diese Aktivität mache, wie, wie, wie viel, wie groß ist dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass mir das eine Corona-Infektion, ne? Ein Entschuldigung, ein Tod, ne, äh, einbringt. Ähm.
Das ist äh also sozusagen in in Mikrokowit gemessen die Inspiration dafür.
Ist schon die Ansteckungsgefahr. Er.
Ist die Ansteckungsgefahr? Okay, gut, das äh habe ich jetzt durcheinander bekommen, auf jeden Fall ähm orientiert sich das wohl von der Idee her an etwas, das heißt Mikromord,
und das ist dann sozusagen äh dasselbe Ding, die Maßeinheit für das Risiko an irgendetwas zu sterben. Was interessant ist.
Also da werden dann zum Beispiel so äh Risikofaktoren gemacht, die dann ein Mikromord haben, äh also sozusagen eine Millionstilwahrscheinlichkeit äh daran zu sterben, ist sowas wie eins Komma vier Zigarettenrauchen.
Also eins Komma vier Zigaretten rauche, dann habe ich mein Sterberisiko um ein Millionstel erhöht.
Das heißt, wenn ich eins Komma vier Millionen Zigaretten rauche, dann bin ich eigentlich schon tot. Halber Liter Weide reicht auch aus, eine Stunde im Kohlebergwerk verbringen äh.
Zwei Tage in New York leben. Ein Jahr lang das Trinkwasser von Maia, wie trinken all so eine Geschichte. Hundert über Kohle gebratene Steaks essen an unsere Grillfreunde. Na ja, also,
es gibt lustige Einheiten auf dieser Welt und jetzt haben wir auch noch Mikro Cowit.
Dann haben wir über die Hunde berichtet in Finnland, die da an einem äh Flughafen stehen, da wurde uns dann auch gleich,
äh richtet, äh gibt's einen schönen Artikel im Spiegel, der so erklärt, wie den Hunden das so beigebracht wird, ein äh längeres Interview, das haben wir äh auch nochmal dann in den Shownotes
Nebst einem schönen Video, dass das eben auch bei der Bundeswehr gemacht wird, da ist allerdings nur davon die Rede, dass die ausgebildet werden, da waren auch nicht davon die Rede, dass die auch zum Einsatz kommen. Ob das jetzt irgendwo so ist
nicht sagen.
Dann gab's noch ähm zwei ganz interessante Hinweise auf andere Projekte, die ähm auch mit den Daten was machen.
Du das ja auch machst, Pavel, da haben wir jetzt noch nicht zu sehr drauf geschaut, aber vielleicht erwähnen wir es an dieser Stelle nochmal. Äh unter anderem, dass es wohl auch aus diesem Via versus Virus Projekt äh hervorgegangen ein sogenanntes Dunkelziffer-Radar.
Hast du da schon mal draufgeschaut.
Ja und hat mir eigentlich ganz.
Gefallen äh muss ich sagen. Vielleicht auch deswegen, weil die Ergebnisse äh äh dort sich mit meinen eigenen
Einschätzungen auch weitgehend gedeckt haben. Also,
Wenn man da drauf schaut, sieht man auch, dass hier ungefähr so äh irgendwas zwischen fünf und sieben an Dunkelziffer hatten
in der Anfangsphase und dass die jetzt irgendwo auf zwei bis drei runtergegangen ist
jetzt in den letzten Wochen durch Ausweitung auch von Tests und und allem, also das passt ganz gut zu meinen Vermutungen und von daher ähm
Ja äh macht das äh auf mich Sinn und äh ist tatsächlich was äh was ich,
auch überlegt hatte äh eventuell zu machen und ähm ja auch das Modell, was dahinter steck
macht irgendwie auch Sinn und äh ja also,
ist natürlich nicht auch nicht die hundert Prozent reine Wahrheit aber es ich halte das für 'ne brauchbare Abschätzung was die da gemacht haben oder was was da läuf.
Gibt's unter Kowit neunzehn Punkt Dunkelziffer, Radar Punkt DE. Dann äh,
ähnliches Projekt von der Uni in Jülich, wenn ich das richtig sehe, äh Uni oder Fach.
Also Juli vom Forschungszentrum, aber beim Supercomputing Center.
Haben sie mit allerlei Mathematik ein Modell gebaut, was nicht nur die Zahlen wiedergibt, sondern auch noch vorhersagt, also da ist unter anderem dieses Now-Casting drin, das haben wir ja hier auch schon ein paar Mal gesprochen, was das RKI ja auch macht, was quasi aus.
Den Meldedaten, den Meldedaten sozusagen das zu erwartende Geschehen der nächsten oder der letzten Tage noch mit reinrechnet und äh von daher versucht eine Aussage über die Gegenwart
zu leisten plus das dann hier mit entsprechenden Modellen auch noch ein bisschen in die Zukunft geschaut wird für vier oder fünf Tage.
Ja? Also im Prinzip ist das Maschinenlearning äh was äh dort gemacht wird und was dann ja Vorhersagen machen
soll ähm sich jetzt mal
angucken, äh wie gut das läuft, wie mein Problem mit Maschinen Learning Modellen ist, dass die dann wenn sie einmal trainiert sind, eigentlich ganz gut
laufen so äh und ganz gute Vorhersagen machen, bis halt irgendwie das System sich verändert, also bis irgendwie was Neues halt eintritt äh und dann
ja, versagen die halt erstmal bis sie denn wiederum darauf eintrainiert sind. Das heißt das ist jetzt,
halt ja, solange sich nichts an den Annahmen ändert oder an dem bisherigen Verlauf äh ist es okay, aber wenn sich's ändert und dass äh sich da Sachen ändern, das kann das Modell halt nicht so
ohne weiteres Vorhersagen und auch ich hab halt ein bisschen damit rumgespielt und es sagt halt.
Prinzip für alle Landkreise steigende Zahlen voraus.
Das können wir auch.
Das können wir auch pauschale Aussagen hier. Das ist da sind wir richtig gut drin.
Also zwischen also steigend und stark steigend. Ich habe bislang bei meinen Stichproben habe ich keine Landkreise gefunden, wo das Modell im Moment sinkende Zahlen vorhersagt.
Damit werden wir dann eigentlich auch schon bei dem Blog, wo wir mal gucken, wie sieht's denn eigentlich aus in Deutschland? Grad nicht so gut, oder? Die Kanzlerin war gestern schon ein bisschen sauer, hatte ich so den Eindruck.
Ja
Also die Zahlen sehen in der Tat nicht gut aus. Wir haben heute am fünfzehnten zehnten zwanzig zwanzig muss man auch ja immer.
Zusagen haben wir einen neuen Rekord mit sechstausendsechshundertachtunddreißig
neuen Fällen oder positiven Tests was,
weitgehend zwar nicht ganz das Gleiche ist, aber auf jeden Fall gab's noch nie so viele positive Testergebnisse ähm,
in Deutschland wie heute
und ja auch die der sieben Tage Schnitt ist zwar noch nicht ganz äh auf Anfang April Niveau, aber wenn das so weitergeht wovon
man erstmal ausgehen kann, dann ist das eine Frage von Tagen maximal einer Woche, bis wir dann auch beim sieben Tage Schnitt,
ähm.
Jahr den Rekord haben auf Bundesebene. So die berühmte Reproduktionsziffer, also meine mein sieben Tage R je nach Berechnungs
Methode gerade zwischen eins Komma drei und äh eins Komma vier
und leider sieht man auch weiter einen Anstieg bei den Todes
zahlen und ja das ist ein heute auch einige dazu gekommen und es ist zu befürchten
nachdem ja jetzt auch wieder mehr ältere Leute erkranken, dass wir äh da leider wieder einen,
Anstieg haben werden in den nächsten Wochen. Ähm,
Der Anstieg ist auch in den in den Zahlen,
echt, weil die Testzahlen liegen auf dem Niveau der vorigen Wochen, aber die positiven Quote ist halt deutlich angestiegen, also wir sind jetzt,
bei eins Komma eins sieben Millionen Tests pro Woche,
und äh ja die positiven Quote ist auf von eins Komma sechs sechs auf zwei Komma vier acht Prozent gestiegen, also,
satt, ähm.
Sollten wir vielleicht nochmal kurz erklären, die positiven Quote.
Ja, na ja es wurden halt,
eins Komma eins sechs sieben Millionen Tests gemacht und davon kamen neunundzwanzigtausend positiv zurück und das sind eben die zwei Komma vier acht Prozent von denen die getestet wurde.
Waren positiv.
Was man dieser Zahl ja im Prinzip immer meint, ab ablesen zu können ist.
Umso kleiner dieser der Anteil an den Tests ist, der halt positiv ausfällt, umso sicherer kann man sich auch sein, dass man das Infektionsgeschehen im Prinzip auch schon ganz gut sieht.
Was.
Also
Wir hatten ja sonst immer die Frage, wenn plötzlich die Tests verdoppelt werden äh von einem Tag auf den anderen, dann würde sich würden sich auch die Zahl der positiven Tests oder der der Fälle verdoppeln, ohne dass sich aber notwendigerweise,
irgendjemand oder doppelt so viele Leute angesteckt haben, deswegen ist es halt immer wichtig, wenn man sich die Zahlen äh anguckt
äh äh was halt mit der Zahl der Tests passiert
ist und wenn die so einigermaßen gleichgeblieben ist und auch die das Testregime gleich geblieben ist, kann man halt davon ausgehen, dass tatsächlich die Infektion
mehr geworden sind und nicht nur einfach mehr getestet wurde und so sieht es halt aus. Ähm ja mehr Infektion.
Ja ähm es kann man.
Sonst noch sagen zum Bund. Ja in meiner äh äh Risikoliste mit den Landkreisen sind jetzt.
Deutsche Landkreise als Risikogebiete ausgewiesen, sofort hatten wir noch nie. Ja,
also ebenfalls seit dieser jetzt diese Liste gibt,
und ja und in den Top dreißig haben wir jetzt sieben Mal NRW vertreten, fünfmal Bayern, fünfmal Berlin, bei
Bayern halt viermal so viele Einwohner hat oder dreimal so viele dreieinhalb Mal so viele wie Berlin. Äh Niedersach.
Hat nur dreizehn Bezirke, also wir sind gut dabei.
Äh ja, also äh ja äh Niedersachsen ist dreimal vertreten, das Saarland zweimal.
Eure Partyhauptstadt lässt grüßen.
Aber wir haben Spaß dabei.
Sachsen, zweimal Hessen, zweimal Baden-Württemberg, zweimal und Thüringen und Rheinland-Pfalz jeweils einmal. Also.
Sieht schon es verteilt sich halt auf eine ganze Menge Länder, wobei bisher nur,
Moment Berlin und Bremen Risikoländer sind, also mehr als diese fünfzig pro hunderttausend Fälle in den letzten sieben Tagen hatten. Äh.
Und äh zusammen mit Saarland, NRW, Hessen, Sachsen und Baden-Württemberg
Ja, treiben, die das Risiko oder die die Zahlen hoch während die Ostländer halt mit Ausnahme von Sachsen und Berlin alle Unterbundesdurchschnitt,
liegen bei den Institzen, also wir haben interessanterweise auch im,
bunt eine ähnliche Situation wie in Berlin, äh auf das sich auch jetzt ein bisschen näher,
eingehen möchte äh in Berlin haben wir nämlich,
auch ähm so ein bisschen äh Zweiteilung bei den Bezirken.
Und zwar liegen auch die reinen Ostbezirke, also Pankow, Treptow-Köpeningen,
Nick, äh, Marzahn Hellersdorf und Berlin-Lichtenberg ähm liegen alle am Ende der Tabelle, während so vorne Neukölln Mitte reinickendorf
Tempelhof-Schöneberg, Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg und Spandau liegen, wobei natürlich Mitte und,
Friedrichshain Kreuzberg jetzt sagen Mischbezirke sind aus ehemaligen Ost und West teilen aber ja.
Können schon äh interessanterweise
wie auch in Berlin, gerade die Tendenz beobachten, dass die Zahlen äh sagen, eben in der ehemaligen DDR äh nicht so stark äh ansteigen, äh wie
im äh Westen.
Außer eben in den in den durchgehend drifizierten Bezirken.
Ja äh.
Also an der Stelle ist es wirklich äh äh lustig, ne? In meiner ich weiß gar nicht, was daraus machen soll. Ich meine, das hat natürlich auch.
Gründe ist mal so schwierig, ne? Ich meine,
Was natürlich jetzt Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, da habe ich mich immer wenig gewundert und das gilt ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch für Schleswig-Holstein. Das sind halt einfach mal wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr dünn besiedelte ähm Bundesländer. Und das gilt ein Stück weit natürlich auch für Sachsen-Anhalt, Sachsen
et cetera. Die haben zwar dann auch noch ihre Metropolen, aber irgendwie keine Ahnung äh was es ist. Ähm aber,
Der Osten scheint irgendwie nicht so betroffen zu sein. Es kann natürlich auch damit zu tun haben, dass die ganzen jungen Leute, die jetzt äh äh wie wir ja auch gleich nochmal besprechen werden, die die Infektion so durch die Leute tragen.
Diese ganzen Dörfer da halt alle früh verlassen haben, ne? Und äh.
Mhm.
Die schlechte Erklärung.
Also so eine richtig genaue schlüssige Erklärung. Dafür haben wir jetzt nicht anzubieten. Wir können ja auch nur spekulieren irgendwo die in Medien wurde auch schon spekuliert, dass sie irgendwie
äh ja die Leute im Osten irgendwie staatsgläubiger sind oder Regel äh,
gläubiger und sich deswegen mehr an die Regeln halten oder vorsichtiger.
Kann ich mir irgendwie nicht so richtig als Erklärung durchgehen lassen.
Wie gesagt, ist reine Spekulation.
Auf jeden Fall in Berlin ist es irgendwie alles schlimm und deswegen ähm reagiert auch die Politik und setzt alle Ampeln auf Grün.
Dass äh ja
Das ist das leidige Thema mit der Berliner Korona Ampel, was wir hier auch schon äh vor ewigen Zeiten, also ich glaube, im im Juni schon.
Hatten, nachdem die eingeführt wurde, als das RKI auch den sieben Tage RW eingeführt hat.
Zeitgleich und man deswegen wahrscheinlich keine andere Wahl hatte als dann, weil's den zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Noch nicht gab oder man noch nicht davon wusste, dass es diesen Ehrwert gibt, hat man halt den sagen Viertages R Wert genommen, der halt wie Hölle schwankt und der dazu führt, dass wir halt eine Flackerampel haben, die selbst in Zei,
wie jetzt ähm so dann am Wochenende immer wieder auf grün,
schaltet zwischendurch, weil halt ja am Wochenende halt so nicht so viele Leute sich testen lassen und weil die Ärzte zu haben und äh ja auch nicht so viele Tests ausgewertet äh werden
ja deswegen geht die springt die Ampel halt immer wieder auf auf grün und
da das außerdem so definiert ist, dass die Gesamtampel.
Ist halt äh rot, wenn zwei Ampeln auf rot sind, aber wenn zwei Ampeln auf grün sind, ist halt die Gesamtampel auch oft grün,
So und die zweite Ampel ist halt die mit der Auslastung des Gesundheitssystems, also.
Gibt's natürlich auch gelb.
Ja, gelb gibt's auch, äh ja, gibt's auch äh so, also wenn zwei Ampeln gelb sind, dann äh ja, aber Gelb sind dieses fast nie, die springen immer hauptsächlich von von.
Grün auf Rot und wieder zurück. Also.
Ja, aber das andere Problem ist mit der zweiten Ampel, wie gesagt, das ist die Ausgesundheitssystemsauslastungsampel und.
Wenn die auf rot geht, dann ist eh zu spät, ja? Dann ist äh sowieso schon dann äh äh,
kann man sicher sein, dass weil das die Zahlen ja auch immer ein, zwei Wochen hinterherhinken, äh dass das Gesundheitssystem dann äh überlastet ist, selbst wenn die Ampel auf Gelb.
Ja, äh, es bleibt nicht mehr genug Zeit, um daran irgendwas zu ändern, so und ja, deswegen ist halt,
obwohl wir äh auch in Berlin einen neuen Tagesrekord hatten,
ist die Berliner Corona Ampel auf grün, weil halt äh irgendwie niemand im Senat sich entweder die Mühe gemacht hat oder es,
hat oder keine Ahnung äh dabei hätte man einfach nur äh diese Ampel
ändern müssen auf einen Siebentages-Ro und an die Schwellwerte ein bisschen anpassen und so, aber ja, das ist halt, das lässt halt nicht,
gutes hoffen, so fragt man sich natürlich, okay, wenn sowas wie die Corona-Ampel, die ja so ein auch was vermitteln soll, was kommunizieren
soll äh an die Leute draußen, wenn das so schlecht durchdacht ist, äh was es da mit den Maßnahmen äh sind, die halt ähnlich gut durchdacht wie die Corona-Ampel oder was ist da los.
Ja und ähm ja äh bei den bei den Maßnahmen ähm.
Die zielen ja jetzt äh ja gut, erstmal muss man sagen bei Maßnahmen, egal welche man trifft, irgendeine Wirkung werden die halt schon immer haben.
Problem ist nur ähm ja hat äh.
Steht es im richtigen Verhältnis zueinander. So der äh zu erwartende oder zu erhoffende Effekt und äh die Einschränkungen, äh die man da vornimmt,
und man möchte natürlich jetzt nach,
sechs Monaten Erfahrung mit dem Ganzen auch nicht wieder in so einen super exzessiven allgemeinen Logdown gehen, aber das kann man natürlich nur vermeiden, wenn man äh ja,
gezielt äh effektive,
Maßnahmen beschließt. Wenn man irgendwelche Maßnahmen beschließt, die aber nicht effektiv sind, dann landen wir halt am Ende wieder beim allgemeinen Logdown, so. Und ähm ja.
Und wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, eine der wenigen aktuell zugänglichen,
Informationen oder Daten, die man.
Bekommen kann äh vom vom RKI ist halt die Institanz in verschiedenen Altersgruppen. So, wo breitet sich das denn äh gerade aus? Und.
Für Berlin und das trifft aber grundsätzlich auf alle Bundesländer auch zu.
Ist es so, dass in der Altersgruppe der ja zehn bis Dreißigjährigen sich hauptsächlich alles abspielt gerade mit einem Schwerpunkt bei den zwanzig bis vierundzwanzigjährigen
zu. Da äh grassiert die Infektion derzeit am meisten. Also in der Altersgruppe jetzt zwanzig bis vierundzwanzig sind
ja
Sieben, acht Mal so viele Leute betroffen wie äh in den Altersgruppen über siebzig. Ja. Das ist also einerseits positiv, weil äh nämlich in diesen,
Altersgruppen, sag mal bis dreißig fast niemand stirbt, also wir haben.
Bislang ein Todesfall in dieser Altersgruppe durch Korona seit Beginn äh der Erfassung. Also das.
Also in Berlin.
In Berlin, ja. Genau, in Berlin, das heißt.
Das ist sozusagen jetzt noch Glück, was auch die Sterberate noch unten hält, weil in Altersgruppen einfach nicht so viele Leute sterben, aber ähm.
Man sieht halt auch, dass es in den älteren Altersgruppen,
angezogen hat. Und zwar haben sich dort die Werte ja teilweise so verzwanzigfacht bei den über achtzig gegenüber vor zwei Monaten,
Äh was habe ich gesagt, verachtfacht.
Verachtfacht im Verhältnis zwischen den niedrigen Altersgruppen und den äh älteren Altersgruppen.
Der, ne? Nein, also bei den älteren Altersgruppen sozusagen vor vor zwei Monaten war nun ein Achtel so viele Neuinfektionen in der Alters äh Gruppe und äh.
Also steigt an, es steigt halt nur bei den jungen Leuten noch sehr viel stärker an, aber man kann, also wir haben ja hier auch so verschiedene äh Heatmaps im Blick, die äh quasi über die ganzen Kalenderwochen hinweg
dass eben für bestimmte Alterskohorten im zehn oder fünf Jahre sind da, weil je nachdem wodrauf man schaut, aufbrechen
Dann ist halt relativ klar zu sehen, als wir die erste Welle hatten.
Da war's dann so, dass sehr schnell eben die Alpen sehr stark betroffen waren. Klar, das war alles neu. Man hat ein normales Kontaktverhältnis äh äh gepflegt und,
Sehr schnell wurden alte Leute infiziert, entweder die Familie über,
treffen, über Veranstaltungen, über Altersheime, was auch immer dazu beigetragen hat, Supermarkt, alles quasi und dann war die Auswirkung groß. Jetzt ist es so, wir haben ein extrem starkes Ausbruchverhalten bei den Jugendlichen.
Und bei den Mitdreißigern und ähm die Alten sind.
Davor besser geschützt, weil natürlich Maßnahmen in Plays sind, weil man vorsichtiges Verhalten hat, weil Altersheime besser geschützt sind, weil wir einfach generell natürlich sind quasi, ne, wir sind,
Und ähm deswegen ist diese Trennung noch stärker da, trotzdem diffundiert es halt in irgendeiner Form. Trotzdem nach oben.
Und es ist ein bisschen schwierig einzuschätzen was daraus resultieren wird jetzt.
Ja eigentlich leider ist es gar nicht so schwierig einzuschätzen. Ähm weil wenn man sich das anguckt, sieht man erstmal ganz klar, was man,
anderen Ländern auch überall sehen konnte, dass wenn es in einer Altersgruppe explodiert ist, dass es dann in allen anderen Altersgruppen dann auch hochgegangen ist. Das heißt äh niemand hat es geschafft, die Alten zu schützen
ja zu sehr man sich auch bemüht hat oder nicht bemüht hat so
ja und das zeigen die Zahlen halt gerade auch ganz klar, dass es in Berlin gerade auch nicht klappt. So und da können wir jetzt schon sagen, bei.
Jetzigen Neuerkrankungen in den äh hohen Altersgruppen, also bei den Leuten, die jetzt schon positiv getestet worden ist, äh können wir sagen, wir werden.
In den nächsten Wochen.
Und daran lässt sie nichts mehr ändern. Das ist jetzt sozusagen bereits passiert, äh, werden wir einen deutlichen Anstieg.
Äh sehen äh bei den Todesfällen so, dass es unvermeidlich würde ich sagen.
Ja und ähm wie das dann weitergeht, ja. Gute Frage. So ähm.
Reichen die Maßnahmen aus jetzt um äh das Ganze zum Stillstand zu bringen. Hm.
Ja, die ich meine, welche Maßnahmen haben wir denn? Maßnahmen wurden denn ergriffen? Also ich meine, in Berlin gibt's jetzt eine Sperrstunde, das heißt, die Bars müssen um dreiundzwanzig Uhr zumachen. Es wird irgendwie auch extrem viel über Alkoholverbot geredet, was ich ehrlich gesagt.
Gar nicht so richtig nachvollziehen kann, was das jetzt groß bringen kann. Das ist glaube ich immer so ein bisschen so diese These mit einer ja, wenn man betrunken ist, da ist man ja ausgelassen und dann hält man ja den Abstand nicht mehr.
Sagen muss, hm, weiß ich nicht, das also das ist mir irgendwie zu kurz gedacht. Ähm.
Ja und natürlich zunehmendem Maße wieder Kontaktbeschränkungen mit anderen Worten. Es gibt Einschränkungen für Treffen.
Wir haben Maskenpflicht auch in Unternehmen, andere Länder sind ja schon ein bisschen weiter, in Italien ist Maskenpflicht auf der Straße,
Da kann man natürlich drüber diskutieren, bringt das was draußen, ist doch so sicher und so
Ja, ist es vielleicht auch, aber ich glaube, ist eine interessante Disziplinierungsmaßnahme, wenn alle Leute auch schon draußen wissen, so, also kaum, dass ich meine Wohnung verlasse, ist Maske angesagt.
An dem Umkehrschluss bin ich nicht zu Hause und bin nicht irgendwo drin, dann ist Maske überhaupt gar keine Diskussion. Das das ist eigentlich der.
Oder dass es dazu führt, dass die Leute einfach nicht so viel Bock haben rauszugehen, wenn sie eine Maske aufsetzen müssen. Das heißt
äh es führt dazu, dass sie deswegen alleine äh schon dazu gebracht werden, nicht so viel rauszugehen und nicht so viel andere Leute zu treffen. Viell,
mehr darum als.
Und vor allem ja und und genau, also man man befiehlt ihnen nicht drin zu bleiben, aber man macht's halt einfach ein bisschen unangenehmer draußen zu sein, trotz alledem kann man dann halt so den äh den Beschäftigungen noch
noch nachgehen, wenn man in der äh wenn man bereit ist, diesen Kompromiss einzugehen.
Ja. Das Problem ist natürlich nur äh so
halten sich die Leute dann auch tatsächlich dran, ähm was man in Israel ganz gut sehen konnte, die ja ähm ja explodiert sind ähm,
und dann auch in den Lokdown, die uns so ein bisschen voraus sind, ist, dass es bei der zweiten Welle halt äh nicht mehr diese Solidarität gab, die man
Bei der ersten Welle noch irgendwo hatte, wo alle auch ein bisschen geschockt waren und sagte, was ist los und die Straßen leer waren und man merkte dann ja so, wie die sich dann nach und nach gefüllt haben und so
und ja und in Israel so äh lassen jedenfalls verschiedene Berichte.
Vermuten oder liegen nahe dass.
Dort eine Menge Energie da reingesteckt wurde, die Maßnahmen zu umgeben. So
und das eben aber auch, ja, einfach äh dadurch, wenn man jetzt selektive Maßnahmen macht von den unterschiedlichen Gruppen
anders betroffen sind, dass man natürlich äh deutlich mehr auch Streit und Unruhe in der Bevölkerung kriegt, weil natürlich jeder, der,
irgendwas übermäßig oder oder direkt betroffen ist und andere sind davon nicht so betroffen, empfindet das natürlich als
entweder Ungerechtigkeit oder als ungerechtfertigt haben wir jetzt auch gesehen so Klagen von äh Wirten gegen
halt die, jetzt ging das Alkoholverbot und gegen die Sperrstunde und äh.
Auch jetzt gegen das Beherbeugungs äh Verbot. Wir sind also auch zum Beispiel in Niedersachsen jetzt gerade durchgekommen. Also da wurde der klare Stadt gegeben, der Beugungsverbot in Niedersachsen ist gekippt worden.
Okay, das hatte ich noch gar nicht mitgekriegt. Ich hatte nämlich Profit, ich hatte auch Profit Zeit, das jetzt äh auch nämlich die Gerichte,
genauer hingucken werden und mehr Maßnahmen kippen
werden, weil äh die Gerichte zurecht auch erwarten können, dass wenn eine Maßnahme jetzt verabschiedet wird, dass also eine spezifische, von der nicht alle in gleichem Maße betroffen,
sind.
Dass das dann auch gerechtfertigt ist, weil wir haben ja so ein Willkürverbot unter anderem, dass die Verwaltung darf nicht einfach irgendwas tun ohne guten Grund,
ja? Von dem dann nur bestimmte Leute betroffen sind. Das muss dann halt durchaus schon gerechtfertigt sein. Und.
Da fällt uns jetzt so ein bisschen, ja, die die schlechte Datenlage äh auch auf die Füße so ähm beziehungsweise,
Die Datenlage ist gar nicht so schlecht, nur die Daten sind entweder nicht öffentlich verfügbar oder ähm,
beziehungsweise und äh die offiziellen Stellen, die Zugang zu den Daten haben ähm.
Kommen nicht mit der Auswertung oder haben nicht genügend Fantasien oder ich weiß es nicht. Jedenfalls ähm.
So ganz, ganz viele Fragen, die seit langem eigentlich brennen, müssten sich,
bereits beantworten lassen, sind aber unbeantwortet, nämlich ähm ja.
Welche Berufsgruppen eigentlich stecken sich am meisten an. Ähm wo erfolgen äh die Ansteckungen, wie welchen Einfluss haben Wohnverhältnisse,
also bevölkerungsdichte oder auch wie viel Quadratmeter oder Räume
Leute zur Verfügung haben auf die Ausbreitung. Wie sieht's bei,
Schülern und Studenten und Lehrlingen aus. Ist es da sieht es da gleich aus? Oder gibt es da
Unterschiede, ja? All solche Dinge
müssten sich eigentlich beantworten lassen, aber scheinbar hat entweder niemand Interesse daran oder keine Zeit dafür oder findet das unwichtig so, aber,
das sind halt genau die Dinge,
den die man bräuchte, um spezifische Maßnahmen gut begründen zu können und die Wahrscheinlichkeit auch zu erhöhen, dass diese Maßnahmen dann auch was bringen und den Lokdown vermeiden, ja. Wenn wir weiter so im Nebel rumstochern.
Ich sage mal einem Alkohol oder einem Beherbergungsverbot. Klar, ich zweifel nicht an, dass beides irgendwas bringt, aber es ist jetzt ein Prozent oder drei Prozent oder fünf Prozent und auch wenn man guckt, wie viel brauchen wir denn
um wie viel müssten wir die Zahlen denn jetzt runterkriegen? Kann man, glaube ich, sagen, das wird nicht reichen, ja? Das wir,
jetzt schon absehbar nicht reichen. Es wird vielleicht ein bisschen äh für eine Verlangsamung sorgen. Vielleicht.
Aber ja äh die Umkehr, ich meine, was wir wir brauchen, wir müssen den Air jetzt wieder unter eins kriegen.
Und da sind wir weit weit von entfernt.
Was natürlich in dieser Diskussion auch immer wieder reinkommt und da äh habe ich auch eine Auswertung äh gesehen auf Twitter hat mal jemand, die äh den Anstieg der Institution in den einzelnen Bundesländern genommen und mal gegeneinander verschoben diese Kurven
so dass sie an der Stelle übereinander lagen, wo die Sommerferien beendet waren.
Und daraus konnte man dann ganz schön sehen, dass es na ja.
Also ich will das jetzt mal nicht einen Beweis nennen, aber es ist äh relativ deutlich, dass eben überall die Zahlen sofort nach oben gingen, nachdem die Sommerferien beendet waren in den einzelnen Bundesländern.
Also absolut klar und deutlich, ne? Überhaupt gar keinen Zweifel dadran,
heißt das natürlich nicht unbedingt, dass es dann auch der Grund ist, ja? Das kann auch andere Gründe äh haben, ne. Also es muss nicht unbedingt nur sagen wir mal so, es kann der Grund sein, aber es muss nicht zwangsläufig bedeuten, dass es in Schulen passiert,
Weil auch Eltern kommen aus dem Urlaub zurück und äh gehen sozusagen nach dem Sommer wieder ihren Tätigkeiten nach, was äh sicherlich alles auch nochmal so ein Treiber war, aber,
zusammen mit dieser Information, dass eben derzeit die infizierten vor allem.
Was ist gesagt? Ab zehn ja bis äh paar und zwanzig na ja.
Das ist jetzt erstmal nicht unbedingt das typische Elternalter so, das geht dann halt.
Doch eher so bei dreißig, fünfunddreißig los in Deutschland, das ist eben nicht so der der Kernbereich
Aber die Schüler sind halt voll mit drin und von daher kann man schon sagen, könnte das eine Rolle spielen. Jetzt haben wir ja natürlich gerade,
Herbstferienzeit, ne? Also zumindest in Berlin haben sie gerade angefangen. In anderen Ländern waren sie vielleicht schon oder kommen erst noch. Das verteilt sich dann auch mal so über vier Wochen, aber eben ungleichmäßig.
Ja. Also wir haben also man kann sagen in dieser Altersgruppe zwanzig bis vierundzwanzig oder fünfzehn bis vierundzwanzig oder sogar zehn bis vierundzwanzig, wo man äh.
Ähm jetzt ja vor allem Schüler,
äh und Studenten hat ja ähm.
Also in den Altersgruppen ging es in der, in den jungen Altersgruppen ging's ab der KW dreißig, das ist so Ende Juli äh äh fingen die Zahlen eigentlich an,
zu steigen, dort bis wann gingen die Sommerferien in Berlin.
Sommer in Berlin länger.
Also, ich kann mal kurz äh Sommerferien, Tabelle hier mal aufrufen, also Sommerferien endeten in Berlin am siebten August.
Mhm. Also sagen zwei bis drei, also mitten in den Ferien ging's sagen schon mal hoch, was daran.
Alle am letzten Tag zurück, ne?
Genau so äh also man kann sagen Mitte der Sommerferien gab es einen Anstieg, was,
darauf zurückzuführen sein könnte. Also oft ist es so, dass hier entweder die erste Hälfte oder die zweite Hälfte äh die Leute wegfahren, dass das sagen die Reiserückkehrer waren, die dann drei Wochen weg waren.
Du hast auch ähm oft den den Effekt, dass am Anfang der Sommerferien noch so ein, zwei Wochen lang die Kitas offen haben und dann machen die auch zu und dann geht das eigentlich mit der Reiseaktivität erst richtig los.
Ja? Und so richtig äh aber den Boost äh sagen.
In die jetzige Phase der begann so in der KW vierunddreißig bis sechsunddreißig irgendwo äh da kann sagen eigentlich KW sechsunddreißig.
Kurz ein Datum dazu sagen, dann kann ich dir das hier mal in Sommerferien einordnen.
Und ja und das ist Ende August ähm.
Okay, also Ende August ähm.
Ging's richtig los in den Altersgruppen, in den Jüngeren.
Also eigentlich überall von, ich sage mal von zehn bis vierzig hoch, ja.
Sommerferien sind extrem verzerrt, ne? Also Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, da enden die Sommerferien.
Ich rede jetzt von Berlin, ich rede jetzt nur über ich rede jetzt nur von Berlin.
Du redest nur von Berlin, okay, gut, ja, in Berlin, wie gesagt, siebter achter ist Schluss. Aber und äh Brandenburg äh dasselbe.
Also es deutet auf jeden Fall hin, wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, dass Schulen einen Faktor.
Sind so, aber nicht der alleinige oder nicht der Hauptfaktor.
Ja äh weil äh sagen das tatsächlich das das Hauptgeschehen eher sich bei den zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen.
Abspielt, ja? Die zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen treiben in Berlin seit fünf Wochen äh langen die Zahlen nach oben. Ja.
Das sind dann auch nicht die Universitäten, weil die sind eigentlich leer. Da ist alles Remote zumindest in Berlin. Ähm.
Das dann bleibt halt noch übrig. Ausbildungsstätten, Orte, Arbeitsplätze,
Ähm oder halt Freizeitverhalten, was er gerne unterstellt wird, dass äh nur die Berliner Partys an allem schuld sind, dass äh glaube ich genauso wenig.
Oder im Zweifelsfall der Fußball, glaube ich, übrigens auch überhaupt nicht. Ähm ja, da stehen wir jetzt einfach.
Aber der eigentliche Klage war ja eine Datenklage mal wieder, ne? Wir,
nicht genug Daten, um solche Informationen jetzt auch mal herauslesen zu können oder dass da Projekte gestartet werden können, die das vielleicht auch mal unabhängig vom RKI Analysen äh analysieren können
denn im Prinzip gibt es ja diese Information.
Und ich will jetzt auch nicht ausschließen, dass irgendjemand
in den Gesundheitsämtern oder überhaupt ja beim Senat wirklich Plan hat, sodass sie eigentlich oder beim RKI wissen, was da abgeht.
Kann es nur nicht immer nachvollziehen so und vor allen Dingen kann ich halt auch nicht nachvollziehen,
welche Maßnahme eigentlich aufgrund welcher,
Datenlage, welcher konkreten Datenlage getroffen wird. Dass die Zahlen hochgehen, das Wissen, ne? Äh so, aber sie gehen halt in allen Altersgruppen hoch,
so, aber das ist fast das Einzige, was wir wissen. Es gibt,
gut. Eigentlich erfassen die Gesundheitsämter auch äh jetzt mittlerweile ganz viele andere Umstände.
Äh unter anderem eben auch Hinweise auf Orte, wo das Ganze stattgefunden hat, aber halt, das wird nicht regelmäßig ausgewertet. Das ist die letzte Auswertung, die ich gefunden habe, ist.
Zwei Monate alt, ja,
Äh dabei ist, dass wir das natürlich super interessant äh alles zu wissen und eigentlich ja sogar auch eine vielleicht etwas,
Finer, räumliche Unterteilung als jetzt die Bezirke. So wer vielleicht auch nochmal hilfreich. Äh dass man.
Das Ganze nochmal, ja, dass, dass man sehen kann, wo sind denn jetzt tatsächlich,
Hot Spots, weil das sind ja mehr so Hot Areas äh jetzt, die wir, äh die wir statistisch haben,
Ja und äh jedenfalls sehe ich jetzt gerade,
dass das uns aber vor allen Dingen auch der Politik und damit dann doch wieder uns allen auf die Füße fällt, dass halt nach wie vor im Dunkeln gestochert
wird und die Maßnahmen nicht begründet werden. Ich habe versucht halt auch jetzt mal in dieser.
Äh Berliner Verordnung, Korona Eindämmungsverordnung heißt das Ding glaube ich, da steht ja eine Menge drin, vermutlich auch eine Menge Sinnvolles. Aber.
Ich hab keinerlei Hinweise gefunden.
Warum jetzt einzelne Sachen da drin stehen oder wie die da reingekommen sind aufgrund welcher ja Razio, die dahinter steckt.
Und äh ja, hat sich das jemand aus der Nase gezogen, war das einfach nur eine gute Idee auf Verdacht oder gibt's da, ja, irgendeine.
Begründung äh dafür, warum bestimmte Dinge nicht getan werden, äh äh dürfen und äh so. Das fehlt mir einfach komplett und ja.
Bei uns zusammen mit dann mit sowas wie der Korona Ampel, ja. Äh so.
Mit der Berliner Corona Ampel. Das stärkt jetzt gerade nicht mein Vertrauen darin, dass die Maßnahme irgendwie zielgerichtet und effektiv sind.
Auch wenn sie sicherlich helfen, keine Frage, aber ja bin unzufrieden.
Unzufrieden. Ich merke das schon, ja, das kann ich auch ganz gut nachvollziehen. Ähm das sind wir natürlich alle, weil wir das ja im Prinzip ja auch schon von Anfang an
diese Story. Also wir hatten vor Monaten hatten wir diesen Datenbrief
den Datenjournalisten, da ist genau überhaupt nichts passiert in dieser Hinsicht. Man hat sie noch nicht mal dazu geäußert, man man hat irgendwie keinen Weg, wie man da ähm man Diskussionen aufmacht, mal das Gespräch sucht, irgendwie ein Forum äh hat in irgendeiner Form
Ja, bla, bla, bla, Überlastung und so weiter, dann stellt man halt mal auf die Leute ein, also das äh ist auch nicht so das Problem da mal ähm für einen entsprechenden Kontakt zu sorgen
und das ist so ein bisschen das Problem. Ich denke, man hat sich ein bisschen sehr auch darauf ausgeruht jetzt so hier als Musterschüler weltweit zu gelten.
Tut man ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch, wenn man jetzt mal Neuseeland ignorieren, aber das kann's ja nicht sein und äh wie wir jetzt sehen, ist es auch kein keine Garantie dafür, dass es nicht doch.
Schlimmer wird. Und jetzt wird's halt gerade wieder schlimmer und wir können uns auf ein etwas äh einsamen.
Wintereinstellen habe ich so den Eindruck. Also Weihnachten haben wir ja schon festgestellt, nicht so geil.
Und äh ja jetzt haben wir sozusagen die neudeutsche Welle, die aber nicht ganz so unterhaltsam ist wie wie früher.
Ist das Problem,
Gut, äh dann versuchen wir doch mal zumindest äh uns besser zu fühlen, indem wir äh anschauen, wie andere Länder das alles noch viel schlechter hinkriegen als wir.
Ja ein Blick äh in die Welt.
Da müssen wir gar nicht so weit gucken. Also schon unsere Nachbarländer, insbesondere unsere unmittelbaren Nachbarländer, also alles was direkt an Deutschland angrenzt mit der Ausnahme vielleicht von äh Polen und.
Mit der Ausnahme von Dänemark sieht gar nicht so gut aus. Ganz weit vorne, Tschechien,
gefolgt von Belgien, gefolgt von den Niederlanden, gefolgt von Frankreich, da geht's so richtig zur Sache
Aber alle Zahlen gehen nach oben und auch Österreich, Polen und was halt sonst noch irgendwie an Deutschland so grenzt, einschließlich der Schweiz,
Alles reckt sich nach oben und wir sind zwar noch unterhalb dieser ganzen Länder, aber eben auf dem besten Weg da auch,
Aufzuschließen. Mittlerweile ist die EU in den Zahlen, hat sogar, glaube ich, sogar die USA überholt.
Ja, nicht ganz, ne, ne,
Also wir sind in der Nähe, wir sind äh noch äh deutlich äh drunter, aber ähm ja, also jetzt bei den Zahlen der neu infizierten. So, also.
Mal in der Grafik, wir sind so bei zwei Drittel äh allerdings jetzt ungefähr als äh Europa äh bei den
täglichen, also bei der Insidenzusagen, also pro pro Million Einwohner. Wir sind
irgendwo also Europa.
Ist gerade irgendwo bei ja hundertsechzig würde ich sagen pro Million und die.
USA bei zweihundert pro Millionen, also sogar.
Nee, also laut Auerworld and Data lehnen wir gleich auf. Und ich spreche jetzt von European Union, ne? Nee, Europe. Also ähm
aber das ist auch, macht auch keinen großen Unterschied. Also USA, Europäische Union, Europa, wie man's auch immer nimmt, äh ist von den Zahlen her ziemlich identisch
also zumindest und auch in der Drei-Ektorie vergleichbar, weil es geht natürlich auch in den USA wieder hoch, nachdem sie ein bisschen runtergingen, steigert sich das Ganze das Geschehen auch. Also es ist einfach wirklich absurd, wie schlecht der Westen mit dieser ganzen Situation fertig wird.
Definitiv. Ja. Also gut, aber man kann festhalten.
Alle Nachbarländer stehen schlechter da gerade, aber wir stehen auch nicht gut da, weil ich noch also positiv sehen grade.
Bisher Griechenland und Norwegen aus. Bei den Infizierten Zahlen aber.
So. Ich glaube, in Griechenland stimmt was mit den Zahlen nicht. So, weil ähm.
Schaut man sich nämlich die Zahl der Toten an in Griechenland sieht man dort einen deutlichen Anstieg im Gegensatz zu.
Norwegen und das in den letzten Wochen, also das passt irgendwie nicht so richtig ähm eher zu den,
Infektionszahlen, die wir sehen, die.
Eher unauffällig waren und deswegen irgendwas ja irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Ja ähm und überhaupt, wenn wir jetzt mal, weil ja, sagen die bei der,
spielt natürlich die Dunkelziffer noch eine große Rolle, das heißt ähm das ist immer mit so ein bisschen Vorsicht zu genießen ein bisschen,
genauer äh aber ja ist dann doch in der Regel die Zahl der Verstorbenen.
Und wenn man sich die jetzt auch noch kommulativ anschaut, dann kann man so ein bisschen äh sehen so ja wie,
hat denn jetzt eigentlich ein Land bisher die Bevölkerung geschützt, so einem einerseits von Anfang an, also zu Beginn und wie sieht es jetzt gerade in der, in der Phase aus?
Und da ist hier von der sagen wir mal,
ja Europaländerliste plus äh USA plus Russland. Ähm.
Belgien äh einfach am schlimmsten.
So, also in Belgien sind halt bisher die meisten Leute äh an Kovit neunzehn gestorben.
Neunhundert von einer Million.
Neunhundert von einer Million. Das ist so fast jeder Tausendste.
Ist äh dort ein Kovit äh gestorben. Das ist heftig und,
Spanien an äh zweiter Stelle und bei Spanien kann man sagen, auch wie Belgien ist es halt wie in den meisten Ländern, nicht in allen äh ist halt die Zahl der Toten,
Am Anfang so zwischen März und April bis in den Mai hin extrem stark angestiegen.
Dann war so bis ja August war relativ Ruhe,
und seitdem äh zieht es äh in Spanien äh wieder an, zieht es in Belgien wieder an. In Italien nicht ganz so sehr ähm,
Ja und Tschechien, was ja so lange Zeit äh so Musterland war und auch kaum Infektionen hatte.
Und dementsprechend auch kaum Todesfälle ähm so ist jetzt,
Prinzip seit ja, in den letzten vier Wochen steigt dort die auch jetzt die Rate der Toten stärker an, als äh irgendwo anders und.
Ähm sie ist zwar noch nicht dort, äh wo äh Deutschland ist, aber ja, fast, also hat jetzt sozusagen die,
sagen Toten, die.
In Deutschland im April äh aufgetreten sind, so die Leute sterben jetzt in Tschechien äh gerade,
mit einer deutlich steileren Kurve gerade, die also die nicht wirklich gut aussieht.
Ja. Ähm ansonsten hat aber die USA jetzt sogar UK bei der Zahl der,
Toten Pro Millionen Einwohner auch überschritten. Äh,
Ja, UK hat's auch geschafft, mit Verspätung allerdings. Äh sich zu stabilisieren äh und zeigt jetzt aber auch einen steigenden äh,
Trend wieder an. Weniger äh ja mehr bisschen mehr als Italien, aber weniger als Frankreich und Spanien oder Niederlande.
Ja also.
Richtig was los.
Ja richtig was los tatsächlich. Hattest du noch, du hattest noch was zur Situation in UK.
Ja, es ist mehr so eine, so eine Einschätzung. Also das ist halt einfach generell in äh UK halt einfach das Problem, dass sie einfach.
Coverment technisch auch voll in der Krise sind. Äh meine dieses Johnson, diese Johnson Regierung, die hat ja nun wirklich schon was Trampeskes.
Ganzen Auftreten und hat auch wirklich das Gefühl, dass sie alle Ministerien
wirklich nur noch mit so ja Sagern besetzt haben, die alle irgendwie überhaupt keinerlei Ahnung haben von dem, was sie da tun und dementsprechend schlecht wird es halt alles äh geführt
Da gehen die Zahlen halt gerade richtig auseinander und vor allem ist halt die Zahl der Hospitalisierung extrem hoch. Also die sind jetzt schon wirklich kurz davor, wieder so an diese Belastungsgrenze zu stoßen, wo sie schon mal waren.
Und das war halt nicht gut, weil sie diesen National Health Service einfach überhaupt nicht mehr im Griff haben, dass das schon in der normalen ähm Bedingung.
War da einfach alles schon nicht mehr in Ordnung und natürlich unter dieser Belastung ist es natürlich nochmal schlechter. Man kann es immer hoffen, ne? Wir haben neue neue Medikamente, man hat mehr Erfahrung mit der Behandlung et cetera,
dass es dann eben nicht in dem selben Maße zu Todesfällen führt, nur wenn du einfach deine Kapazität ausgelastet hast, dann hast du deine Kapazität ausgelastet, dann kann's aber irgendwann auch nicht mehr ordentlich arbeiten.
Ähm ja, das ist äh,
insbesondere dieses ganze Test und Tracing. Ich meine, wir wir haben ja jetzt hier auch schon viel geschimpft, ne, äh über Gesundheitsämter oder sagen wir mal, wir schimpfen ja hier eigentlich mehr nur über die Transparenz,
Wir akzeptieren da, wenn äh wenn Dinge getan, wir können nicht so richtig einschätzen, ob genug getan wird oder wo nicht genug getan wird oder ob man noch in irgendeiner Form
helfen könnte oder dass man vielleicht einfach ein bisschen mehr
ähm es dafür schaffen kann, was denn jetzt wirklich die problematischen Verhaltensweisen sind. Das haben wir ja schon alles besprochen. Trotz alledem
ist es irgendwie am Start. Aber was man halt so in Großbritannien äh hört, ist es halt einfach absurd, ja.
Die schicken dann irgendwelche Testkids raus, die schon mal benutzt waren und äh dann gab's halt diesen fantastischen Vorfall, wo sie einfach ihre komplette Tabulierung der Zahlen,
die Kette bekommen haben.
Wo sie in Excel.
Genau, wo sie also mit mit alten Excel-Versionen, die dann halt entsprechende Beschränkungen haben, also manuell
es ist einfach und der Grund dafür ist halt auch schnell äh gesagt, ja sie haben dann einfach ähm nach der Ankündigung von Boris Johnson, dass sie ein World Beating Test and Shay System haben, das heißt sie sag
diese ganze aufgeblasene hyperbolische Verhaltensweise, wie sie Trump halt auch an den Tag legt. Das ist halt bei Boris Johnson, der auch von Tuten und Blasen her wirklich keine Ahnung hat.
Der geht dann immer raus und sagt so, oh ja, was, es gibt hier ein Problem. Ja, dann kündige ich sie einfach mal an, dass wir jetzt hier das Beste der Welt machen,
So, das ist dann erstmal so das Erste, hat zwar keine Ahnung wie oder was oder worum's eigentlich überhaupt geht, aber es muss dann erstmal wieder so ein super Lativ aus der Schublade rausgezogen werden und da sie dann eben
Nur Freunde äh in der Businesswelt haben, die ihnen dann die ganze Zeit ins Ohr flüstern mit so, hier gib mir Geld und dann kriegen wir das schon irgendwie hin.
Haben sie dann natürlich ein privat organisiertes System versucht aufzuziehen, was dann wiederum mit diesem National Health Service überhaupt nicht verkoppelt war. Also eine Maßnahme
die wir uns in Deutschland jetzt überhaupt nicht vorstellen könnten. Ja, was weiß ich, dann rufst du ja irgendwie bei unserer Managementbude an und sagst, machbar für uns hier irgendwie äh,
dass das Tracing. Das Kontakt Crasing. Also ich meine da da wird auch hier da da würden doch hier die Mülltonnen brennen. Und.
Halt einfach statt.
Ja, wir haben jetzt halt.
So ein bisschen das andere Extrem, nämlich das äh ja, es zweihundert Stellen bei den Gesundheitsämtern gibt, die ausgeschrieben sind und nicht besetzt so und jetzt hat äh unser Finanzsenator.
Nochmal weitere Gelder zur Verfügung gestellt für mehr Stellen gestern oder heute, ich mein ja äh kommt kommt ja echt zeitig ja.
Aber äh das Problem wohl mit den zweihundert Stellen, warum die Besetzung auch so schwierig ist, ist, dass es Anforderungsprofil eigentlich so ist, dass man dafür nur in Frage kommt, wenn man den Job schon mal gemacht hat. Ja, das ist natürlich dann auch besonders intelligent.
Ja
So, wenn man so versucht zu Leuten zu kommen ja also.
Kann nicht funktionieren.
Nee. Ähm.
Aber äh nicht alles im Comment Worlds ist äh äh schlecht. Also ich glaube auch Australien hat's gerade so halbwegs im äh Griff und natürlich Klassenprimus wie immer und wahrscheinlich irgendwie das Land der Glückseligkeit auf diesem Planeten derzeit.
Sollte es anders sein, ist Neuseeland, ja, weil man da mal sich von jungen Frauen führen lässt und nicht von so halten.
Äh na ja gut,
ohne These, aber Neuseeland hat natürlich auch einen Vorteil, dadurch, dass diese jetzt so eine super isolierte Insel sind und auch kein, kein, kein Reisehab sind und was weiß ich. Ja, also sicherlich ein Reiseziel, aber eben nicht unbedingt so einen Reisehub.
Und.
Sind jetzt auch nicht so komplett kovit frei, sie haben so ein, zwei äh Fälle pro Tag, mit denen sie irgendwie zu arbeiten haben, aber das ist natürlich bei einer Bevölkerung, die so groß ist, wie Berlin ein Problem, was wir hier gerne auch hätten.
Ja, also äh sie schreiben.
Gerade jetzt auf der ähm ja no new cases in two Days. Wobei das natürlich sein kann, du sagtest.
Geguckt, da werden schon Fälle. Es kann natürlich sein, dass das sozusagen Einreisende sind,
die Fälle, die bei der Einreise festgestellt wurden, wo die Leute dann in Quarantäne äh äh gepackt wurden äh und möglicherweise ist aber keine Ansteckungen in der Bevölkerung gegeben hat. Das könnte gemeint sein.
Das kann ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, weil die sind da relativ stringent, Neuseeland lässt auch nach wie vor niemanden ins Land. Also kannst halt einfach da nicht rein, so. Ähm und.
Nicht ohne Weiteres. Also ich gehe mal davon.
Wenn du jetzt im Krankenhausbereich arbeitest und so weiter, es gibt bestimmte Qualifizierungen und natürlich gibt's auch bestimmte Ausnahmen und Diplomatie, Pipapo, aber sagen wir mal, ist so als äh Everige Guy. Äh wenn du jetzt sagst, du ach ja, jetzt Neuseeland, Korona frei wäre ja mal geil, da fahre ich jetzt mal hin. Äh.
Ja. Ja.
Gut, dann schauen wir nochmal kurz äh auf ein paar interessante Studien oder beziehungsweise Studienvergleichsergebnisse. Da ist mir was äh über den Weg gelaufen.
Auf Gitarb. Wobei äh verschiedene Studien herangezogen wurden über Covet neunzehn als Krankheit und
äh das Ganze in Vergleich gesetzt wurde zu den äh wohlgemerkt äh Verläufen in US
A der Grippewellen, also es sind jetzt quasi Daten, die sich ausschließlich auf die USA beziehen oder zumindest kommen die von der US CDC. Ich vermute mal, dass sie sich dann auch nur,
äh die USA bezieht und dass es dann eben einer nach ähm Alter,
ähm aufgestellte Untersuchung, wie groß eben die ähm.
Infection Fatility Ration ist, also wie viele Leute sterben äh von den Infizierten, also die Fallsterblichkeit.
Welcher Altersgruppe.
In welcher Altersgruppe.
In verschiedenen Studien über Cover neunzehn und in verschiedenen Jahreszahlen quasi den offiziellen Berichtszahlen der Grippeverläufe aus den einzelnen Jahren seit zweitausendundvierzehn.
Und das, da gibt's dann so einen Plot, der spricht eigentlich eine relativ deutliche Sprache, da kann man einfach sagen,
Ja so bei jungen Leuten, wo die Fälle ohnehin, also wo diese Sterblichkeitsrate extrem niedrig ist, da,
nimmt sich jetzt so Kuvitt und äh Grippe nicht so viel. Da spielt sich so beides in etwa in der selben Liga ab, auch wenn man schon sehen kann, dass Kurve zu tendenziell mehr reinhaut,
Aber kaum, dass man so bei einem Alter von dreißig Jahren angekommen ist, entfernen sich dann doch die
mediane oder Mittelwerte äh sehr schnell voneinander, sprich,
alle Grippeverläufe der einzelnen Jahre seit zwanzig vierzehn die biegen dann deutlich tiefer ab.
Alle Studien, die derzeit über Cover neunzehn gemacht werden, zeichnen einfach ein anderes Bild und von ja,
Jahresgehort ist von Alter, also von Alterskroorte zu Alterskorte geht es extrem hoch bis zu einem zu einem Unterschied von na ja so zwölf bis zu vierzehnfachen.
Sprich ist vierzehn Mal so tödlich für Siebzigjährige.
Und genau, also ja und für Dreißigjährige ist es immerhin schon dreimal so tödlich, äh ist Kurve dreimal so tödlich wie die Grippe.
Genau bei vierzig sind's vier Komma sieben, bei fünfzig sind's acht Komma zwei, bei sechzig sind's dreizehn Komma zwei, also so schießt es dann nach oben.
Das heißt ähm so ja das einfach ähm.
Dass die Gefahr zu sterben im Prinzip exponentiell mit dem Alter zunimmt.
Weil wir haben ja auch einen exponentiellen Graphen und das läuft äh und die Kurve Kurven laufen irgendwie fast gerade,
dem exponentiellen äh äh Grafen während die äh Grippe äh Kurve so ein bisschen ab,
knickt mit zunehmendem Alter, was glaube ich wiederum damit zu tun hat, dass äh es eben.
Die Grippeviren, die rumkommen, halt äh viele Leute ähnliche Viren schon mal
gesehen haben und eine Teilimmunität zumindest äh haben in den älteren Kohorten. So das ist glaube ich äh die Begründung äh.
Dafür warum weniger ältere Leute Angriffe sterben als bei Kobit.
Es gab da jetzt auch im letzten Drosten-Podcast nochmal ein paar äh Reflektionen über so ein paar Studien, die äh ähm wesentlichen,
angeschaut haben, inwiefern halt jetzt Infektionen mit Corona Viren, da äh unter Umständen helfen können gegen Kowit entsprechende Immunität aufzubauen.
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, ja, zeichnet sich ab, aber ist halt alles noch nicht genug, um hier wirklich äh nennenswerte Unterschiede zur Wirkung von Grippe zu haben.
Gut, ich denke, da können wir jetzt mal mit den äh Zahlen und Maßnahmen schlachten erstmal aufhören. Ähm und gucken wir doch nochmal.
Was so in der digitalen Bekämpfung der Krankheit so für Fortschritte gemacht wurden, beziehungsweise welche Fortschritte hier noch gemacht werden können. Wir haben ja auch schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen,
Akzeptanz der Korona Warnapp. Na ja, es ist immer noch irgendwo zwischen gar nicht so schlecht, aber auch nicht total bahnbrechend viel.
Die Downloadzahlen steigen langsam. Sind jetzt.
Wo liegen wir jetzt.
Neunzehn Komma eins Millionen. Das ist so eine ganz langsam ansteigende Linie.
Erinnerst dich, was ich vorher gesagt hatte.
Ja, ja, ja, ich, ich hatte irgendwie, ja beziehungsweise ja, irgendwo in der Nähe zu zwanzig Millionen hatte ich, glaube ich, entweder zwanzig Millionen oder zwanzig Prozent, ja. Aber.
Da zwanzig Millionen. Darauf läufst, läuft's jetzt hinaus? Es sei denn, es gibt halt da nochmal besondere Gründe
warum man das äh haben möchte
wenig überraschend, steigen auch die Zahlen an mit den wo jetzt Schlüssel veröffentlicht werden und ich weiß nicht ob du so in den letzten Wochen mal auf deine Choronabahn App geschaut hast.
Ja, ich hatte.
So mal so aufgemacht hast.
Kontakt.
Genau und ich hatte auch mal drei und ich kenne auch Leute, die hatten mal fünf und die hatten auch nochmal ein paar mehr. Also man ist schon.
Häufiger jetzt in dieser Situation, dass man einfach in seinem normalen Leben und ich muss sagen, ich bewege mich jetzt nicht so mega viel durch die Welt. Ähm also Supermärkte und was man halt so macht.
Äh es dann doch schafft, innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen mal so an vier, fünf Leuten vorbeizukommen, die später positiv gemeldet werden und wohlgemerkt, die,
Corona Warnapp verwenden, ja? Also das äh sollte einem schon so ein bisschen zu denken geben und an der Stelle äh finde ich ist das auch mal ein interessanter Monitor, ähm da würde ich mir halt auch mehr wünschen
dass diese Aktivität, dieses Rauschen mehr wie soll ich sagen, einem mehr vermittelt wird.
Ohne jetzt gleich so, du bist in Gefahr, sondern einfach so dieses Happening, ja? Du bewegst dich immer mehr
äh bis immer mehr von Leuten so umgeben. Ich finde, dass diese ganze Sprache, die da mit einem gesprochen wird, einerseits noch zu akademisch ist, zu Textlastig ist und am noch nicht so richtig das Gefühl gibt, was man vielleicht,
vermitteln sollte.
Plus, was wir ja was war das, was die italienische oder spanische Korona waren.
App, wo zumindest wo direkt in der App dann auch die Zahl irgendwie der Warnungen und so.
Ja, die Schweizer machen das, ich glaube, die Iren auch, ja.
Die ihren waren's glaube ich.
Ja, genau und das sind alles so, das sind alles so Dinge, äh wo so ein bisschen Gamification reinkommt, wo wo es auch einfach mal interessant ist, mal die App aufzumachen, weil man da Informationen sieht. Und wenn der gesamte Up,
den ich hier sehen kann ist so und so viele Begegnungen mit niedrigem Risiko. Das ist das einzige was da passieren kann. Warum sollte ich das aufmachen.
Ja vor allen Dingen, was ich ein bisschen nervig fand, war äh dass es keine Möglichkeit gibt, das Datum rauszufinden, wann diese Begegnung stattgefunden hat.
Man man erhält ja dieses Datum aber erst wenn man sozusagen jeden Tag nachschaut. Die kennen Leute, die machen das, die machen das jeden Tag auf.
Und notieren sich dann immer um wie viel weniger Begegnungen es geworden sind, was natürlich auch nur begrenzt funktioniert, weil es kann natürlich immer sein, wenn hinten eine,
einer dazu kommt, dann weißt du es halt auch wieder nicht, ne? Und vor allem was in aller Welt, wo also wer soll, wovor beschützt werden.
Also Datenschutz am Allfolz, ja? Wenn's sinnvoll ist, okay. Aber an der Stelle finde ich es einfach gar nicht sinnvoll. Denn es würde einem einfach sagen.
Gestern du hast dich irgendwo was heißt gestern, also gestern ist wahrscheinlich unwahrscheinlich, ja? Vor einer Woche.
Hast du dich einfach irgendwo befunden? Und da ist es dir gelungen irgendwie ein oder zwei oder drei Leute äh in deiner Nähe zu haben, die sich
Tage später dann als positiv gemeldet haben. Das ist doch eine wichtige Information. Ja, ich weiß, da kann man dann theoretisch rausrechnen, wo man da gewesen ist, wenn es wenige Leute waren, dann weiß ich schon wieder, wer es ist.
Ja okay, gut ja vielleicht so, aber man verpasst hier meiner Meinung nach vor allem erstmal 'ne Chance, weil,
Das ist schon etwas,
Womit ich jetzt nicht unbedingt gerechnet habe, dass man diese Datensparsamkeit so weit äh äh runterschraubt. Weil es einfach auch für mich eine wichtige Information ist, mein eigenes Verhalten
zu ändern und ich denke, das sollte so ein bisschen das Ziel sein, dass diese App nicht einfach nur so ein reiner Datenbringer ist, sondern mehr so eine Art Verhaltensassistent.
Na ja, jetzt gab's ja noch eine,
Zweite Diskussion und wir haben die hier, glaube ich, ansatzweise auch schon mal ähm geführt, nämlich immer so diese Frage deckt denn dieses Proximity-Trasting? Wie kann man das jetzt im Prinzip ja nennt, also dieses.
Nachschauen, wer ist mir zu nahe gekommen? Deckt das alles ab. Und wir wissen, einerseits ist diese ganze Bluetooth-Sache natürlich ohnehin schon schwierig
ne? Also ist nicht dafür gemacht und man kann jetzt tausend Mal darüber diskutieren, ob das jetzt überhaupt geeignet ist und ob da die richtigen Signalstärken berücksichtigt werden und selbst
Wenn die richtigen Signalstärken berücksichtigt werden, selbst wenn man einen richtigen Abstand errechnet, ist der dann überhaupt relevant, weil sitze ich jetzt mit jemandem in drei Meter Abstand,
in einem Raum drei Stunden na ja, also dann macht der halbe Meter jetzt.
Auch keinen großen Unterschied mehr, weil die Suppe zieht dann halt einfach durch den Raum. Und.
Man hat sich halt immer gefragt, okay, wie kann man das Ganze jetzt vielleicht noch um Dinge ergänzen, die für bestimmte kritische Situationen noch einen weiteren Nutzen bringen.
Und was ja viele andere Länder machen ist
so 'ne Art Check-In, das gab's schon von Anfang an in äh äh China und äh vielen anderen Ländern. Ich habe da jetzt alles andere als einen Überblick, auch die neue UK-App
hat so ein Feature mit drin, sodass es eben die Möglichkeit gibt, dass Orte äh.
Letztlich ein QR-Code veröffentlichen und ich kann, beziehungsweise in China muss diesen QR-Code scannen und sagen, ich.
Ich bin jetzt hier gewesen. Die Frage ist, wem sagt man das, ne,
China und alle Überwachungslastigen Staaten ist natürlich klar wie es läuft so, du hast da irgendwie eine ID und danach weiß man ganz genau so und so Personen war dann und dann da und da. So und dann daran irgendwie teilgenommen oder hat da rumgehangen. Und selbstverständlich ist das irgendwie nix
Was wir jetzt irgendwie haben wollen. Es gibt jetzt ein neues, interessantes White Paper
von Leuten, die auch maßgeblich an dieser ganzen Entwicklung von diesem DP drei T Protokoll, was ja später die Basis für Exposa Lotification von Google und Apple war, äh die daran mitgearbeitet haben
und haben das jetzt äh mal veröffentlicht, das ist so quasi der erste Aufschlag, um da Feedback einzusammeln,
von der Community und und da äh in Diskussionen zu kommen. Das Ganze nennt sich Crowd, Notifire.
Und das äh die Idee dahinter ist das sogenannte,
Presents Tracing. Also wir haben derzeit,
Proximity Tracing, also nachvollziehen, wer war in meiner Nähe? Und das haben wir ja hier auch ausführlich diskutiert, dass das dann eben so gebaut wurde, um maximal,
Datenschutz und Anonymität sicherzustellen, aber trotzdem ein System zu haben, mit dem man Leute warnen kann.
Und hier geht es jetzt im Prinzip.
Mehr oder weniger dieselben Ziele, also auch hier soll alles möglichst datensparsam, anonym etcetera äh gebaut werden, um Leute zu motivieren, daran auch teilzunehmen, weil sie nicht das Gefühl haben, müssen, dass sie irgendwelche Informationen irgendwo hinterlassen, wo sie das nicht möchten,
Aber eben das auch mit so Smartphones durchführen zu können, weil viele Leute haben halt einfach mal eins dabei, haben eine Kamera da drin, da kann man das halt irgendwie machen.
Das Ganze nennt sich Crowd Notifire, die Centralize, Privacy Preserving Presence Tracing.
Und wieder viele Ps, aber sie haben davon abgesehen dem Ganzen wieder so eine kryptische Abkürzung voranzustellen, sondern hier ist halt einfach generell von Crowd, Notifire, die Rede. Das heißt, hier geht's dadrum, eine Benachrichtigung
zu erhalten.
Wenn sich nachträglich feststellt, dass an einem Ort oder einem Event irgendwie jemand positiv getestet wurde.
Und das Ganze ist explizit als eine Verlängerung des normalen Contact Racings, der Gesundheitsämter oder sonstiger Health Assorities,
gedacht, sprich es wird halt festgestellt, Person X war bei einem Event und dann soll man eben.
Über den Organisator dieses Events äh eine Information gewinnen können, um dann in der Folge alle zu benachrichtigen. So, hier, hör mal, du warst auf diesem Event, da ist jemand positiv gewesen.
Denk mal drüber nach. Das ist sozusagen das Ziel. Sie haben sich jetzt ähm ausführlich mit dieser ganzen Problematik,
ähm beschäftigt und haben vor allem erstmal, wie man das eben auch machen sollte in so einem Whitepaper die ganzen Probleme äh aufgeschrieben, die man
so abdecken möchte. Also welche Voraussetzung möchte ich jetzt haben, ne? Vor allem, sie haben sie erstmal gesagt, was sind denn überhaupt die Probleme, die wir heute bei dem normalen Location-Training haben,
nicht, also kennen das ja alle, man ist im Restaurantmeisterknappe, was muss man machen, man sollte sich halt um eine Liste eintragen.
Was machen die Leute? Sie tragen sich nicht in die Liste ein oder sie tragen irgendwas in die Liste ein oder sie tragen es so in die Liste ein, dass es nicht lesbar ist oder nicht stimmt oder keine Ahnung.
Und vor allem,
selbst wenn dann eben so ein Vorfall geträst werden soll, dann muss halt das ganze Papier nehmen, musst es dann erstmal alles erfassen, dann erstmal rausfinden, was sind denn da überhaupt für Kontaktwege? Steht da eine E-Mail drin, ist die richtig geschrieben, funktioniert die überhaupt?
Seine Telefonnummer kann man die anrufen, ist an der Adresse, kann man da was hinschreiben.
Mühsam, dauert lange und vor allem skaliert ziemlich schlecht, umso populärer so ein Ort ist. Ja, hast du jetzt irgendwie in so einem Restaurant und dann ist äh jemand, der da bedient.
Fünf Tage lang äh.
Positiv rumgerannt, von Tisch zu Tisch. Na ja, dann hast du halt in einem größeren Betrieb schnell mal so tausend, zweitausend Gäste gehabt.
Kriegst du halt einfach nicht notifiziert. Das funktioniert irgendwie alles gar nicht.
Ähm ja, von daher will man das natürlich in irgendeiner Form digital machen und ein anonymes Notification-System aufbauen.
Rund um die Idee, dass man halt an etwas teilnimmt.
Also die Grundidee hier ist, dass man eben von Orten spricht oder von Events. Das kann also sowohl etwas sein, was einfach an einem Ort ist, also Kneipe oder eben was sich durch die Gegend bewegt, so eine Demo oder sowas.
Das ist eigentlich wird äh äh wird offen gelassen. Und man möchte eben bestimmte Dinge nicht machen, weil man sieht halt
In dem Moment, wo man jetzt so wirkt, einfach so ein Erfassungssystem macht mit äh X war auf Y an äh Datum Z. Da hast du natürlich das Problem, dass so schnell ein System hast,
wo Leute, die hinterher schnüffeln können, wo sie Druck auf dich ausüben können, äh ob du da warst oder ob du da nicht warst. Ähm man möchte dementsprechend keine
zentrale Datenhaltung haben und man möchte natürlich auch die Privatsphäre der Leute schützen, weil in dem Moment wo das sich auch immer etwas Sensitives handelt, ja, also auch eher so eine etwas geheimere.
Nicht öffentliche Veranstaltung.
Möchtest du es ja auch nicht nouncen, das ist die so überhaupt gab. Ja, aber wenn halt nachträglich rauskommt, dass es so ein Treffen gegeben hat, dann bist du halt auch in der Lage.
Trotzdem noch Leute zu,
benachrichtigen. Ich meine, mit so super Geheimnis, dass dass niemand jemals davon erfahren soll, gut, dann nimmst du an sowas wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht teil, aber es man möchte einfach, dass man eben auch noch die Veranstaltung damit abdecken kann,
die noch ähm so ein bisschen unter dem Radar laufen, sagen wir es mal so, ne?
Und das auch nicht unbedingt äh immer klar sein muss, wo das jetzt genau war. Also es muss nicht unbedingt immer klar definiert sein, es muss jetzt nicht eine GPS-Koordinate, eine Adresse damit verbunden sein. Es geht nicht da drum, Orte zu regustrieren
es geht auch nicht dadrum, dass man zwangsläufig nachvollziehen kann worum es sich bei diesem Treffen gehandelt hat.
Man will auch nicht durch das Protokoll selber in irgendein.
Art einschränken oder vorgeben, was genau so ein Ort jetzt sein kann,
ne? Und natürlich ganz klar, man will äh auch nicht, dass später nachvollziehbar äh ist, wer hat jetzt alles an diesem an dieser Veranstaltung teilgenommen? Wer hat diesen Ort besucht? Wie viele haben daran äh teilgenommen und natürlich Klassiker,
dass eben auch so ein System mehr oder weniger nichts zurücklässt, also dass man hier nicht.
Records erstellt, die dann später irgendwann mal groß ausgewertet werden können.
Ja, das sind so ein bisschen die die äh die Ziele.
Und man möchte halt einfach, dass die Nutzer das selber in der Hand haben ähm und äh freiwillig das Ganze äh benutzen.
Das ist so ein bisschen so erstmal als Prolog so,
wie die sich das gedacht haben und aus welcher Denke heraus die jetzt äh hier ein Protokoll ein Systementwurf gehabt haben,
Jetzt gibt's natürlich für dieses Systemdesign äh ein paar Annahmen, die sind äh relativ offensichtlich, denke ich, also man hat,
man möchte natürlich hier mit Apps arbeiten, also man möchte auf dem Telefon,
'ne App haben, die einem bei diesem ganzen Ding irgendwie äh hilft und natürlich.
Denkt man auch da dran, dass man sowas zum Beispiel in eine Korona-Warn-App mit einbaut.
Dass vor allem auch keinerlei Funktionen äh äh mit jetzt in diese äh Warnapp reingenommen werden muss, die dann vielleicht den Betrieb unter den Bedingungen von Google mit Apple als äh Exposé Notification Client
irgendwie stören würden oder so. Ähm.
Und äh das ganze System soll halt auch funktionieren, wenn zum Beispiel die positive Person selbst äh jetzt diese App nicht verwendet, also davon soll's sozusagen nicht abhängig sein, ne, sondern man muss quasi für jeden Event auch nach wie vor diesen Paper Trail
auch noch machen können und die App soll dann quasi das Ganze ergänzen. Also es ist nicht so ein entweder alle oder keiner äh Ding dabei rauskommt.
Und vor allem man will eben wie beim Expoja Notification einfach so auf Vertrauen basieren. Also.
In dem Moment, wo du benachrichtigt wirst, hast du diese Information und wir gehen dann einfach mal davon aus, dass wenn du diese Information hast, dass du dann irgendwie auch das Richtige tun wirst.
Und nicht irgendwie das einfach ignorierst. Kann man natürlich nicht wissen, ne? Aber es ist natürlich das System selber soll kein Zwang
erstellen. Du musst nicht dich zu irgendetwas committen, äh musst dich irgendwas versprechen, unterschreiben oder sonst irgendwie irgendwie einen Vertrag eingehen, sondern du musst einfach nur benachrichtigt und dann
wird dir was empfohlen, was du besser jetzt tun solltest, nämlich im Normalfall dich äh testen zu lassen und ähm,
dich vielleicht dann entsprechend bei irgendwelchen Behörden äh zu melden und beim Contact Tracing mitzumachen, aber eben auch nicht mehr als das.
So wie funktioniert das Ganze jetzt? Die Idee ist, dass.
Man, wenn man jetzt so einen Ort betreibt oder so eine Veranstaltung macht. Na, sagen wir mal, wir machen jetzt hier einen.
Podcast-Meeting.
Und da kommen dann irgendwie Podcaster und man macht irgendwie Vorträge und Pipapo und Workshops und alle rennen halt an an so einem Veranstaltungsort durch die Gegend oder natürlich kannst du es jetzt auch genauso auch für ähm.
Irgendwelche.
Demos oder Kneipen oder Bars, die ihr genauso denken, dann gibt's halt einen Organisator und äh als Organisator würde ich äh jetzt.
Ein QR-Code aushängen, den Leute dann einfach scannen können.
Dieser QR-Code ist im Prinzip so eine Art deiner Eintrittskarte oder deine Visitenkarte, ja das Beispiel will ich jetzt so nicht nennen, aber das das ist sozusagen das Ding, was du scannst, mit dem du sagst, ich.
Nehme jetzt hier teil. Ich fange jetzt an hier teilzunehmen und du kannst optional auch noch einen zweiten QR-Code,
bereitstellen, dass es dann der Exit-Code. Ja, das ist eines der Entrecote, das andere ist der Exit-Code,
und du kannst dann eben auch noch sagen, okay, ich bin jetzt hier raus und scanne halt auch nochmal diesen Exit-Code. Das wäre natürlich dann viele Leute auch vergessen.
So
Sinn der ganzen Sache ist, dass man auf dem eigenen Telefon eine Information erzeugt. Es gibt da etwas, daran habe ich teilgenommen und zwar am um von bis.
Und wenn ich nur diesen Entrecote äh scanne.
Dann ist da im Prinzip auch schon eine Dauer mit angenommen. Also wenn ich diesen Code erzeuge, dann sage ich,
Okay, ist eine Veranstaltung, durchschnittliche Verweildauer liegt wahrscheinlich bei so und zu viel Stunden.
Wenn ich das nicht explizit eingebe, indem ich halt auch noch meine beendete Teilnahme registriere, dann wird es eben, wird davon erstmal ausgegangen, sodass auf meinem Telefon die Information entsteht, okay, es gab hier eine Veranstaltung, habe ich teilgenommen,
an diesem Datum, in diesem Zeitraum. Und das ist es eigentlich auch schon. Du musst halt einfach nur äh.
Einen QR-Kurzscan und das.
War's. Mehr, mehr musst du nicht machen und du kannst es dann halt einfach äh selber entscheiden, das Ganze äh machen.
Wenn dann später festgestellt wird, dass an diesem Ort, an diesem Tag eine Person rumgelaufen ist, die unter Umständen infektiös war, na ja, dann äh.
Wird hier
Kontakt aufgenommen mit dem Organisator, der nämlich zu dem äh Zeitpunkt, wo er diese QR-Codes erzeugt hat, einen zusätzlichen QR-Code noch gemacht hat, sozusagen fürs Mäppchen, der ist privat,
Der enthält einen sogenannten Tracing-Code und darin sind dann eben Daten gespeichert, die man dann in dem Moment rausholt, wo es ernst wird,
So dass dann eben über eine Infrastruktur eine entsprechende Warnung rausgeschickt werden kann,
Das läuft dann so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie bei der Corona Warnapp, das heißt ähm man spricht diese Warnung aus für diesen Event, für einen bestimmten Zeitraum
legt diese Information auf einen Server und die Apps checken regelmäßig diesen Server.
Würde man also das jetzt in so eine Corona Warnapp einbauen, hätte man diese Funktionalität im Prinzip schon drin.
Dieses Ganze, ich hole mir Daten vom Server. Nur jetzt eben andere Daten zu einem anderen Zweck. Das kann man ja dann eben entsprechend kombinieren und dann würde man eben diese Information bekommen und die App selber.
Siehtan, aha, hier Vorfall auf diesem Event. Äh da gucke ich doch mal, ob ich da entsprechend dabei gewesen bin,
und dann wird man halt äh gewarnt, je nachdem, ob sich die eigene Beteiligungszeitraum mit dem genannten Zeitraum äh überlappt.
Ja, das ist jetzt aber erstmal so grob die Methode, wie das funktionieren soll,
das Ganze koexistiert natürlich dann eben auch mit diesen Papierlisten, ja? Äh und dieser Tracing-Code, den ein Betreiber eines Ortes, äh, Organisator einer Veranstaltung hat
das ist dann sozusagen das Daten-Backup,
dem so ein Gesundheitsabend dann äh diesen ganzen digitalen Weg noch mit in dieses Contectracing mit einbauen kann.
Es ist soweit erstmal verständlich, erklärt.
Ja, also mir ist.
Soweit klar wie das Ganze funktioniert. Ich hatte spontan erstmal so hm also.
So zwei Dinge sind mir aufgefallen, äh wo ich einfach ein Fragezeichen habe, das eine ist die Sache mit den QR-Codes. Ähm.
Ja, hat Vor-und Nachteile.
Wenn ich so einen QR-Code scannen kann, weiß ich zumindest, okay, ich habe ihn jetzt gescannt, aber ich muss ihn halt auch scannen.
Das ist die eine Sache. Wie gesagt, hat Vor-und Nachteile. Das das Ganze.
Und die zweite Sache ja ähm ist,
sagen die Trennung tatsächlich vom,
contact tracing, weil wir hatten ja eigentlich schon mal bei einer Diskussion, wie könnte man sowas machen äh auf die Überlegung mit äh ja äh Location,
Tokens oder Event Tokans oder wie auch immer das äh ja.
Also zumal man ja auch dann sagen, was auch so ein bisschen fehlt jetzt oder wo ich so ein bisschen ein Loch oder eine Lücke sehe ist dass ähm.
Wenn ich.
Jetzt, also ich ich muss halt auch mich dran erinnern und beim Gesundheitsamt dann auch angeben, dass ich auf dieser Veranstaltung war und.
Nein, nein, das musst du nicht. Du scannst nur den Code als Te.
Nein nein, wenn ich jetzt äh sozusagen, wenn ich jetzt bei mir eine Infektion festgestellt wird, so, ja. Und in, äh, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, damit jetzt auch.
Der Ort oder die Teilnehmer dort.
Von dem Event benachrichtigt werden können, hängt es davon ab, ob ich beim Gesundheitsamt auch angebe, dass ich auf diesem Event war.
Ich du als Teilnehmer? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, du gibst dem Gesundheitsamt überhaupt gar keine Information. Alles was du als Teilnehmer der Veranstaltung machst, ist du scannst einen Code.
Aber wie erfährt denn jetzt der Ort, äh dass äh dort ein infizierter war.
Vom Gesundheitsamt, weil das ist ja quasi im Rahmen eines Kontaktracings. Kann natürlich sein, dass dass du das selber rausfindest, ja, aber hier geht es ja dadrum. Also du hast einen normalen Tracingvorgang,
In dem Rahmen wird jemand befragt. Wo waren sie denn.
Aha, sie waren auf dieser Veranstaltung. Da da würde das Gesundheitsamt diesen Veranstalter anrufen und sagen, wir hatten da jemanden.
War auf ihrer Veranstaltung, geben sie uns doch mal äh ihren Paper Trail, wer auf dieser Veranstaltung war, weil sie sind ja verpflichtet, diese Daten vorzuhalten.
Mhm. Genau.
Kommt halt eine Frage noch dazu und die Frage ist, haben sie denn den Crowd-Notifier benutzt? Haben sie denn einen entsprechenden QR-Code aufgegangen? Dann sage ich, ja.
Ah super, dann geben sie uns doch mal den Tracing-Code, den sie in ihrem Mäppchen abgehäftet haben, weil das sollten sie ja tun. Den würden wir ganz gerne mal hochgeladen bekommen und dann.
Dieser Betreiber nimmt seine sein Telefon mit der App,
scannt diesen Tracing-Code, der geht wiederum zum Gesundheitsamt, da steht aber auch nichts drin, was äh in irgendeiner Form irgendjemand identifiziert, sondern das löst dann eben nur aus, dass auf,
Server, eine Information äh bekannt gegeben wird mit hier.
Es gab ein Dings und dann laden sich Leute diese Informationen selber unabhängig runter.
Ja, das ist schon alles klar, aber äh sagen die Lücke, die ich sehe oder das Loch ist, wenn ich einfach, wenn ich jetzt infiziert bin. So und ich war jetzt auf so einer Veranstaltung.
Äh und verschweige das einfach.
Dann weiß es keiner.
Genau, weil ich so, ich habe aber keine Möglichkeit, ohne den Gesundheitsamt preiszugeben, dass ich auf der Veranstaltung war, äh sagen.
Du möchtest gerne,
bekanntgeben, dass das so war. Das der aber da haben wir dasselbe Prinzip dasselbe Problem, wie wir das auch schon bei der Exposa Notification hätten. Damit kannst du natürlich so ein System total zuspammen
Du brauchst eine äh du brauchst eine Intität, die sagt, dass das auch legitim ist. Und das kann in dem Fall ja nur das Gesundheitsamt sein.
Mal anders an. Ich hätte ja gerne, wenn ich schon dann diese App habe, äh also ich hätte sie gerne, ich hätte das gerne kombiniert und integriert in die Corona Fahne.
Und zwar enger äh als es hier in diesem Vorschlag äh jetzt drinsteht, ja,
und zwar enger deswegen, dass äh wenn ich dann mein,
Kriege, um meine äh ja Kontakte mit der Korona Warn App zu warnen, ja,
Dass dann gleichzeitig die Locations mitgewarnt werden. Ja ohne dass ich beim Gesundheitsamt jetzt
irgendjemandem aber sagen musste, ich war jetzt auf der Veranstaltung, damit die waren können, sondern eigentlich äh sind ja die Daten, erstens, ich war auf der Veranstaltung so und zweitens, ich bin infiziert,
sind ja auf meinem Telefon und validiert und eigentlich sehe ich jetzt keinen Grund warum ich dann
sozusagen den Weg über das Gesundheitsamt gehen muss, nochmal extra um diese Location
zu benachrichtigen, sondern warum kann ich nicht einfach mit der normalen Warnung, mit der die Kontakte gewarnt werden auch über die.
Locations, die Anwesenden an der Location mitgewarnt. Ist jetzt klar, was ich vermisse.
Ich äh ja, sagen wir mal so, ich ich befürchte jetzt gerade so ein bisschen, dass wir jetzt, weil ich will ja noch ein bisschen mehr erklären. Ich war jetzt sozusagen beim ersten Teil, dass wir jetzt
Schon mal zwei Sachen miteinander verwursten, die jetzt erstmal konzeptionell so nicht unbedingt was miteinander zu tun haben. Also
klar könnte man da über irgendwelche Automatismen nachdenken, aber ich glaube, was diesem Entwurf jetzt auch sehr wichtig ist, ist, dass es vollkommen unabhängig von einem von einer Proximity Tracing Infrastruktur funktioniert, da nichts mit zu tun hat, das nicht unbedingt braucht, dass das im Place ist
sondern es ist tatsächlich ein sehr, sehr, sehr einfaches System, was erstmal versucht, dieses andere Problem zu lösen.
Ja, das hat sicherlich, das hat vor und,
Nachteile so und Nachteil ist halt in Verbindung mit der Corona Warn App könnte man es einfacher und privatsphäre schonender implementieren als wenn es ein Standalone System ist. Das war mein Punkt.
Okay, gut, da habe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden, was da dein Punkt ist. Lass uns mal ruhig mal vor und Nachteilen bleiben. Ich will mal kurz mal die Vorteile, die ich jetzt erstmal so sehe, erstmal
aufzählen und dann wollte ich auch nochmal genauer erklären, wie das eigentlich tatsächlich funktioniert. Also, erstmal.
Es ist hier sehr wenig Aufwand. Du machst einen einzigen Scan-Vorgang, also Telefon rausnehmen, Kamera an.
Fotografieren. Ist also Scan in App.
Ähm im Idealfall nimmst du normale Kamera und durch den Inhalt dieses Codes wird dann auch diese App auf deinem Telefon automatisch aktiviert und die nimmt das einfach zur Kenntnis. Also sondern nicht mal die App selber aufmachen musst, ne. Ähm.
Und im.
Umfangreichsten Fall noch ein zweiter Scan, weil wenn du rausgehst und dann ist da so 'n expliziter Ausgang und da hängt dann auch nochmal ein QR-Code, wo drauf steht. Hör mal.
Noch geiler, wenn ihr jetzt auch nochmal sagst, du bist jetzt nicht mit dabei, ne? So, das ist irgendwie alles, was man tun muss, das.
Zumutbar. Das ist etwas, was Leute können, verstehen, machen können et cetera,
Es würden keine Informationen über deinen Aufenthalt, wenn keine Informationen,
überhaupt über dich deine persönlichen Daten, wenn nirgendswo gespeichert, hingesendet, abgelegt et cetera. Es findet keinerlei Informationstransfer von deinem Telefon irgendwo anders hin statt. Null.
Das ganze Matching später führt komplett auf deinem Telefon gemacht, ja?
Keinerlei Rekord in irgendeiner Form an einer anderen Stelle. Es gibt da keine Clouds, gibt da keinen Server, der irgendwas macht. Auch ganz wichtig, das Prinzip erlaubt ist, diesen ganzen Vorgang zu machen, ohne das Internet da sein muss.
Du scannst einfach das Ding auf deiner App und ist egal, ob du da gerade Netz hast, du bist da irgendwie irgendeinem tiefen äh äh Keller oder du bist jenseits von irgendeiner Infrastruktur, es ist nicht wichtig, du brauchst das Internet später nur, um gewarnt zu werden.
Und äh auch hier das System kommt halt komplett ohne so Push-Nudifications aus. Also du brauchst halt auch nicht irgendwelche sekundären Registrierungen und so, sondern so wie das bei der Corona Wahl App auch ist. Äh kommst du hier komplett mit Polling aus.
Schon mal so das Ding, ne? Jetzt gibt's natürlich schon so ein paar.
Probleme, ne? So ein QR-Code hängt irgendwo rum und wird äh ohnehin viel fotografiert. Dann ist er natürlich in null Komma nix auch auf Twitter.
Ne? So oder wird halt sonst irgendwie irgendwie rumgereicht? Und da es quasi ausreicht, diesen Code zu sehen, zu scannen.
Um dann eben in dieser Notification Q drin zu sein,
Kann man natürlich so auch von öffentlichen Veranstaltungen oder Orten relativ schnell, indem man sich das einfach mal so abspeichert und dann für seinem Telefon gegenüber behauptet, so ja, ich war jetzt da,
obwohl ich gar nicht da war, ja. Ich habe das nur so übers Internet äh bekommen, würde ich natürlich dann in dem Moment auch davon benachrichtigt werden.
Man kann das dann auch nicht ausschließen. Gut, ob ich damit jetzt ein, da kann ich mir vielleicht ein Ei draufpellen, aber es ist ja dann auch immer so was wie.
Journalisten wissen dann sofort auf der Veranstaltung war jemand infiziert. Ja.
Ob das dann so ein Problem ist, das hängt dann mal sehr von der Veranstaltung und von den Journalisten oder wer auch immer das Mind für sich jetzt äh ausnutzen zu können ab.
Das ist natürlich schon so ein vielleicht so eine gewisse Gefahr, ne? Solche Enttrikots, die hängen halt rum, die sind dann irgendwie im Netz im Fernsehen, was weiß ich. Äh das ist so das Ding.
Dann
muss man sich natürlich auch fragen, wie oft erzeugt man solche Codes, wie einfach ist es, solche Codes zu erzeugen oder wie schwierig ist es dann auch, diese entsprechenden Tracing-Codes äh korrekt abzulegen
um dann eben das ganze System auch zu ermöglichen. Du willst unter Umständen halt auch etwas genauer sein und nicht jetzt monatelang immer denselben Code verwenden
ne? Also es würde sich zum Beispiel bei so einem Restaurant oder so durchaus hm wäre es durchaus vorstellbar, dass man einfach jeden Tag einen neuen Code macht.
Jeden Tag einen neuen Code aushängen. Einfach, weil,
sich's dann auch nur eben auf diesen Tag von vornherein beschränkt. Du hast zwar dann beim Scannen eben diese Information schon, so, ne? Aber dadurch, dass du halt so durchrotierst, ähm fallen halt automatisch irgendwie Leute raus, die was weiß ich, sich den,
fotografiert haben und sich nochmal abscannen oder was weiß ich, ne? Neuer Code, neues Glück, das wäre äh sicherlich ganz sinnvoll, muss man auch mal drüber nachdenken.
Und es ist natürlich überhaupt eben die Frage, wie einfach ist es, diesen Code zu erzeugen und klar, das müsste natürlich dann in so einer App äh äh gemacht werden.
Oder auf einer Webseite. Könnte man auch machen. Na, also man könnte das auch ohne App machen.
Ich habe mir jetzt auch nochmal die Technik genauer angeschaut so und ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob ich schon alles zu hundert Prozent in allen Implikationen so verstanden habe, aber äh vielleicht für die für die Freunde der Kryptografie
hier nochmal kurz eine Erklärung, wie denn das eigentlich so gedacht ist.
Denn es muss ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch eben so eine Sicherheit geben, ne? Es muss irgendwie sichergestellt werden, dass jetzt hier nicht einfach irgendwelche Leute von irgendwas gewarnt werden, sondern dass es eben,
schon ein moderierter Prozess ist, ohne eben dabei Daten rauszugeben. Wenn das System,
Eingerichtet wird, würde hier zum Beispiel das Gesundheitsamt.
Oder sagen wir mal das RKI in dem Fall erstmal sich so einen öffentlichen, privaten Schlüssel,
so ein Schlüsselpärchen erzeugen. So ein quasi so ein Masterkey, mit dem man.
Alles ermöglicht und damit werden dann eben auch diese QR-Codes äh mitsigniert oder das fließt mit mit in diese Schlüsselgenerierung mit rein.
Und du kannst dir jetzt vorstellen, gehst zum RKI-Satz, ich will eine Veranstaltung machen. Ich möchte jetzt gerne hier so Präsenz Tracing machen
gehst du auf Webseite, sagst ja wie Präsenztraining Punkt RKI Punkt DE. Ja, hallo, okay, schön. Geben sie doch mal hier ihren Namen ein. Dann hast du so ein Stück Jawaskript in deinem Browser, gibst einen Namen und einen Ort deiner Veranstaltung ein. Es wird dann eben eben nicht auf dem.
Server gespeichert, sondern das ist quasi nur in deinem Webbrowser oder alternativ eben in einer App, ja? Die das äh macht und.
Dann wird dir ein QR-Code erzeugt, den du dann eben entsprechend ausdruckst oder abspeicherst oder,
wieder natürlich beides. Wie gesagt, es sind maximal drei QR-Codes pro Veranstaltungen, die man so macht, also einen Entricode, einen Exit-Code und eben dieser Tracing-Code, Entry und Exit-Code geht an die Tür,
Trasingcode geht in die Schublade. Der ist privat und soll nicht rausgegeben werden, weil der ist dann eben später äh.
Erforderlich, um dann eben diesen ganzen Prozess zu starten. Ähm.
Dieser Entrecote, der äh.
Enthält eben diese Information, zum Beispiel eben diese durchschnittliche Dauer des Aufenthalts, das ist da quasi mit äh drin.
Und das wird dann eben alles mit diesem mit diesem Public,
vom vom vom äh vom RKI äh verschlüsselt. Äh dasselbe dann eben mit dem äh Exit-Code.
Da ist dann sozusagen keine weitere Information drin, außer dass sich auf dasselbe bezieht, ne? Und diese ganzen Kies sollen irgendwie so zehn Tage lang äh gelten. Ich weiß nicht, warum wir es auf einmal zehn und nicht vierzehn Tage hier ähm eine Rolle spielen
egal. So und alle Leute scannen sich halt einfach diese Dinger und äh speichern das ab. Wenn's jetzt einen Fall gibt, also es beginnt jetzt quasi das Kontaktracing. Irgendjemand ist
beim Gesundheitsamt vorstellig geworden, wird befragt so, ja ich war ja auf dieser Veranstaltung. Okay und.
Dann kriegen sie halt raus, okay, äh hier ist dieses Personal Tracing zum Einsatz gekommen.
Haben da angerufen und gesagt, hier, wie ist denn bei euch, habt ihr da Pressens äh Tracing? Ja, wunderbar. Dann erzeugt das Gesundheitsamt eine Fallnummer.
Und äh diese Fallnummer wird diesem Organisator dann gegeben, mit der Bitte, diesen Tracing-Code einzuscannen, das heißt, da nimmst du irgendwie wieder die App, scannst diesen Tracing-Code aus dieser
Schublade heraus und daraus kann dann eben
ähm das Gesundheitsamt Name äh und Ort und einen sogenannten Kommunikationskey ableiten. Das heißt, erst, wenn sie diesen Tracing Key haben, sind sie auch in der Lage, diese Benachrichtigungen rauszuschicken.
Und ähm es gibt da so verschiedene Überprüfungen in diesem Zustand, in dieser Phase
die ich jetzt nicht so richtig verstanden habe. Lass dich aber sehr intelligent. Ähm wie sozusagen sichergestellt werden kann, dass sich hier eben auch jetzt um einen gültigen Code handelt,
klar, der ist ja mal mit einem Schlüssel erzeugt worden, et cetera. Also man kann hier sozusagen nochmal gegenchecken, nicht dass jetzt hier ein Tracing-Code von irgendeiner anderen Veranstaltung vorgelegt wird.
Dieser Name und Ort, ja, der nicht vorher abgespeichert ist, sondern der letztlich nur in diesem.
Entri und Exit-Code und in diesem Tracing-Code mit drin ist. Der wird einem übrigens, wenn man das Ding scannt auch nochmal angezeigt. Also es ist Sinn der ganz
Sache ist, du scannst das Ding und du siehst dann in dem Moment auch das, so dass man nicht halt einfach irgendeinen nimmt von irgendeiner veranderen Veranstaltung.
Ja und das äh ist es dann eigentlich im Wesentlichen auch. Also äh das Gesundheitsamt kann dann eben diese Warnung aus,
Auslösen mit diesen Daten, die diesem Tracing-Code drin sind
Also erst dann wissen sie überhaupt wirklich von dieser Veranstaltung und erst dann haben sie diesen Kommunikationskey, mit dem sie dann eben eine Nachricht erzeugen können, die dann eben bei den Betroffenen auch wirklich eine Nachricht äh
auslöst.
Das ist eigentlich so mal kurz gesagt so die Technik. Gut Pavel, dann äh würde ich sagen, bringen wir das mal jetzt für äh diese Sendung zu Ende.
Mhm. Ja.
Ich hoffe, dass ihr alle wieder äh Kommentare äh geben werdet zu all dem, was wir jetzt hier wieder falsch erklärt haben. Ähm grundsätzlich.
Heißt es jetzt.
Aufmerksam sein und ein bisschen zurückhalten, weil ehrlich gesagt, ich hab jetzt kein Bock, dass das jetzt hier alles so eskaliert, dass wir jetzt mit spanischen oder französischen oder sonst sowie irgendwelchen Ländern ähm,
vergleichbar wird und wir hier partielle Lokdowns haben oder noch ausgedehntere Reisebeschränkungen. Allein schon deshalb, weil ich jetzt in zwei Wochen wieder mal eine,
umfangreiche Podcastreise habe, genauso wie ich das schon im März hatte.
Wo ich so akribisch über wochenlang irgendwie fünf Termine schön aneinander gereiht habe.
Wenn die mir dann irgendwie weggebrochen sind so mittendrin und äh ich befürchte gerade genau wieder den richtigen Zeitpunkt getroffen zu haben.
Ja, es sieht im Moment gerade ganz so aus, also dass wir ich meine wir sind noch nicht ganz da, wo wir im März waren, aber vielleicht noch ein, zwei Wochen äh äh weg davon und.
Dann könnte die Panik so richtig losgehen, weil.
Ähm erstmal natürlich die Virze, die nächsten ein bis zwei Wochen werden die Zahlen weiter ungehemmt in die Höhe schießen.
Oder sagen wir mal so, es die Maßnahmen jetzt, wenn sich halt frühestens in einer Woche oder in zwei Wochen.
Ja in den in den Zahlen niederschlagen. So von daher ja.
Schlecht aus für meine.
In die Zahlen jetzt erstmal hoch und nehmen und die Panik wird hochgehen und äh ja ich meine wir haben halt irgendwie einfach zu lange gewartet äh jetzt und jetzt gerade äh
rutscht uns das weg, ja. Ähm.
Mach mir keine Angst. Ich will, ich will jetzt meine ich will das bei sich geplanten Interviewtermine durchziehen. Ich muss hier liefern irgendwie. Leut.
Aber ich mein, ja gut.
Wollen, dass sich äh Podcaste.
Ja, aber äh ich meine dieses dieses Corona ist eigentlich so ein bisschen unvorhersagbar, also
Das ist immer möglich, dass es da äh eine Trendwende oder eine Verlangsamung gibt, aber Anzeichen dafür sind äh gerade nicht bisher zu sehen, also ähm ja.
Sieht nicht gut aus.
Mit diesen ermunternden Worten verabschieden wir euch in die Woche und wir schauen mal, wann wir wieder zu euch sprechen. Vielleicht äh früher als gedacht. Wir sagen erstmal tschüss, ne.